welcome to aj+
a place of non-stop debate and
excitement will circle back to this our
goal here at aj+ is to tell
uncomfortable truths whenever possible
hold on hold up that's all right you've
got a you've got a nose hair thing going
on it's not it's not good to uncover
stories that matter from around the
globe
so pictures for this week so I thinking
about a piece on how Kenya has really
emerged recently to become sort of the
celebrity United Nations which if you
connect the dots right like obviously
makes baby North's the baby celebrity
Ban ki-moon to meet you wherever you may
be
hey did you hear that Ukraine signed a
deal with you
Putin's I can be happy huh we've got the
youthful energy of a start-up but we're
serious journalists I should be in a
suit the israeli-palestinian conflict
stay with us we come from all over the
world
oh hey Christina hello please meet our
hi I'm Christina oh I'm sorry
is it wondering to
Joe I like it I just wanted more grit to
your stylize fun rebellious yeah sure
Charlie yeah you know I did with that
guy just say we're based in San
Francisco so you know we've got an app
and we're just getting started so far as
video views go aj+
is here Gangnam style is here can
somebody tell me what's wrong with this
chart but we hope to get bit yeah take a
look at this there's a cat here it's
rolling around on its back and purring
it's got 14 million views do you think
you could do something like that
so if you want to get with a new
perspective on global news all in the
palm of your hand you look like a nice
person maybe you're in YouTube's are
your to subscribe on YouTube follow us
on Twitter and like us on Facebook